since senzo was there what did he tell
you before
I think just motivate you I think that's
Hansel always did that fantastically
well to motivate me like before I fight
a match I think that you know the
confidence you know he's
you know his energy being around you
it's I think that's the is the great
thing to have hands on your corner is
the motivation that he gives you what
did you learn about Jiu Jitsu and life
from Hanzo Gracie
we got to hang out with him in Vegas a
little bit he's a character he's one of
the uh historic coaches and Jiu Jitsu
competitors but also Personalities in
the martial arts world in in the world
in general there's very few like him
hemsley's a fantastic person it's
it's you know what I've learned most
from him is like it's you know you can't
take any challenge it's you know it
doesn't matter when where
yeah well you know who it's you know you
have to be ready and
you know with that war spirit that he
has he you know he always took any
challenge
Ready or Not Ready
was it you that said it or he said it
where
uh not until
you go in
you know to do something difficult to
discover the strength that you have so
like
like if you really think about it
you might think that you don't you're
not good enough you don't have the
strength to take on something difficult
I fully agreed I think we are measured
not when we're on the strongest but when
we are on the weakest
that's when we truly measure ourselves
or character who we are not we're in a
position of power
or when our position of weakness have
you surprised yourself like how damn
good you are like is this is this really
how good I am in this situation where in
retrospect you might think how the hell
was able to accomplish this not
how good I am because
otherwise I wouldn't be there
so you know being there in the first
place it's it's already not a great
thing but I say you know I've every
single time I found myself there I was
super proud that I've never cracked
like I've never gave up ever any second
any fight never never been broken in
competition never even it's not about
winning or losing is about you giving up
I've never doubt myself I always fought
to the very end always that I'm most
proud of
because there was moments you know it's
you're in a terrible position you know
mainly like there was moments that I was
super tired but like exhaustive tired
when and it was easy to give up like I
had nothing more to give
but I pushed I took
energy out of my soul I would have to
say because when my body had zero my you
know my spirit my soul
pull it out
is that in part just not allowing
yourself to have um
to have to ever ever quit yeah
I have uh one other thing I regret I
remember like a blue belt match
I remember I'm not gonna say who it was
against but uh I remember just being
extremely exhausted
and um just constantly fighting a guy
with a really good Mount really good
guard passing and I just remember
uh him passing my guard
eventually it was just like a finals of
one of the ibgf tournaments
and then
right away going to mount
and just
I don't know I the the level of
frustration I mean I quit at that point
I said I remember that still like I it's
not about losing winning or losing but I
just remember I I was like like I was
like teary-eyed frustrated and then I
knew there was a lot of fights still
left even in there somewhere and I I
quit and I regret that to this day
because uh I think the reason I regret
that is because it gave me an option to
to now quit in every other aspect of
life like that this is an option yeah it
is it sucks
yeah he teaches you you know it makes us
stronger it's actually made you stronger
uh yeah it makes you stronger that you
did that to learn that don't do that
again
um but still like you said just going to
sleep in training
I do think it made me weaker it did make
me weaker in the rest of my life too
that those you know I've quit a few
times in my life on small things and you
realize okay it's not that big of a deal
it's fine
like who cares
um but that what you learn over time is
that voice always comes there like uh uh
obviously maybe it does for you too even
at the highest level of like it's not
that big of a deal like it's okay to
quit here like it makes sense everybody
would understand
um
you know in some sense like you're uh
you know many people would say you're
past your Prime in this match with the
procession like it makes sense you've
been focusing on MMA makes sense yeah it
makes sense to lose yeah uh I don't know
that that's a weird voice and in some
sense uh it's that voice and a voice
that says like why are you doing this
like this is silly that doesn't make any
sense just just stop just stop just stop
and uh shutting that voice down and
never allowing yourself to quit that's a
really powerful thing like everybody
I've met
everybody that's successful
um
yeah down to the even Engineers CEOs
Elon Musk just never quitting
like when everybody around you it says
quit never quitting it's weird I don't
know what that is might be genetic it
might be like using the stubbornness to
just never allow yourself to um
develop that it's basically developing a
calluses to that voice that tries to
tell you to quit you never quit huh what
would you attribute that to
it's like how much you want to get to
the destination you chose like you know
it's how badly when I get there
it's if you quit you're never gonna get
there and you always wanted to I always
wanted